- What up, it's YG folk,
100, Stay Dangerous,
the album coming soon, yeah.
- How are you?
- What's popping, I'm good though.
♪ My songs, my soowoop is so strong ♪
♪ I can't do no wrong,
my woopin' can't be ♪
- Real pleasure, hi.
Sarah, nice to meet you.
Three way, Gavin?
- It's a pleasure.
- Real pleasure.
- How you doing brother, Tyler,
good to meat you brother.
- Gary man, I'm hearing
you the man to come see.
- Well that's fucking flattering.
I like your fucking kicks
man, those are fresh.
- [Assistant] Can I get
anything for you guys?
- I'd love a tea.
- [Assistant] Yeah, you guys
need anything, coffee, tea?
Just black or anything in it?
- Cold water.
- Do you need a chair?
Everybody sat down lady like, like.
- [Sarah] I'm such a
lady, you have no idea.
- [Gary] The most ever.
- The biggest...
- The biggest fuckin' light lady ever.
- [Sarah] Especially when
I'm around with you guys.
- I'm sure, you're the coolest lady ever.
- One thing that's crazy is I've known,
I've known Mezo since like
the beginning of hip hop,
the launch, the beginning.
We've really, we've met when
he started this company.
When he started Vayner
Media that's when we met.
- Back in fuckin' sunshine?
- Yeah.
- You lived in New York?
- He's been in LA though
but he does the merch,
he does the whole 400 thing and...
- That's right.
- He's with YG 24/7.
Me and YG have never met, but
we're so happy to have you man
- Man, it's lit.
- Yeah man, congrats on everything.
- Thank you bro.
- It's real.
- Thank you.
- How does it feel?
- Oh man, I'm chilling, just regularly,
you know what I'm saying?
- Do sometimes though
you like take a step away
for a quick second and be like fuck yes?
Like yes.
- I try to think when I
had one of them moments.
- That's what it is right,
there's just no time,
I don't do it either,
there's just no time.
I kind of feel like I always
do it and never do it.
Like I'm conscious of it.
- Yeah, you conscious, but...
- But I never sit there and
be like oh my blessings.
Like you know, I don't really
have that conversation.
- I think it's, oh no, when I, I like,
me when certain shit happen and shit,
like when I get some me
time, when I'm on the course
sliding by myself and shit
I be like, ah yes Lord.
- Yeah, we did it.
- Then I be like.
- That's the brand, that
was our whole intention
was like we're taking everything
we do and bring it high.
You know what I mean?
Like better ingredients, better quality
with the right intentions
behind it, you know what I mean?
- Of course I understand.
- Brands you know what I'm
saying, like the fashion brands,
like they get a lot of they
influenced by the street culture
- 100%.
- But it don't really
be no, they don't really
involve no real street
mothafuckas in the shit.
Just like rappers and all that.
Like when they blow up,
you know what I'm saying?
But it's like nah, bro like.
- You know what happened, right?
The fucking internet became the middleman,
there's nobody stopping
anybody from the street going
from street to the finish
line, that's what happened.
- Yeah, for sure.
- So like when everyone's
like what's happening?
Simple, BET and MTV and
Viacom didn't let the street
get to a certain level.
They didn't have the distribution.
You don't need them.
Z100 doesn't control, Hot
97 doesn't control anything.
I mean they can, they can help.
But that's, people don't get it,
and it's gonna happen more, not less.
And then it becomes, you know?
- Fire.
- It's very real, and I don't
think people fully understand.
I keep telling people, like
there's nothing stopping
anybody anymore.
There's the perception
of it, there's the way
we think it is, but like it's laughable.
Like the president, media companies,
it went from this to this to this,
from this to this, do you understand?
- Yeah.
- That, look at this, you see that.
Because I'm 100% right.
But look, that's what's up.
People don't get it,
that's what's happening.
- A shift.
- The cool thing they're
doing with their brand too,
the 400, is that it doesn't,
like it's not a T-shirt
that says YG.
- I'm aware.
- You know what I mean,
and like that's so smart,
you know what I mean, it's just so smart
to have a brand that lives on its own.
- And even in front of
that it's not, it's like
really not T-shirts, I mean,
yeah, this is a sweatshirt,
but like I mean the stuff that
we're working on right now
is like crazy.
- So what's the team, I know who you are.
- So I do creative direction and design
for the clothing brand
and then I work with YG
on his music stuff and all
the artists and the labels.
- I understand, so you got,
you got on the music front
you're a partner that
way, a service provider,
but you're a partner
on the clothing brand.
So you guys are really integrated.
Thank you guys, hey T.
- I guess I'll pass 'em out, hi guys.
- Is somebody getting me a
tea, do you know about that?
- Yeah.
- Cool, thank you so much.
Izzy cool, and how about you?
Management.
- [Sarah] We just started
working together maybe like
three or four months ago.
- Oh so it's new.
You guys knew each other for a minute?
- Not really, I mean we've met.
- You guys knew each for a minute?
- Yeah we've known each other.
- [Gary] Yeah, makes sense.
- Actually I, I don't
know if you remember.
Do you remember Summit at Sea?
- Of course.
- That's the first time I ever,
I went to one of your like, your talks.
- When I stood on stage and told everybody
they're full of fucking shit.
- Yeah, I was like, I love this guy.
(laughs)
Everyone who was on Sea
thought they were special
complaining about dumb shit.
- [Sarah] Yeah.
Somebody that we work with and I just saw
some of the other stuff with you.
- Who's that?
- Is it Ryan or whatever,
do you guys know him?
- Yeah, Ryan, he's a good friend of mine.
- [Gary] He's a good dude.
- He's a part of our management
team, he manages all of us.
- [Gary] Got it.
- And we work with a
bunch of good, really.
- [Gary] Artists.
- Really, and our team is pretty on point.
- Stacked.
- They know what they're doing.
They know what they're diong.
- Well I appreciate it.
- What I wanted you to talk about man
for everyone watching too is
just the whole stay dangerous,
you know, like if you wanna
talk about it, explain it.
Like whatever you wanna say about it,
but as like reaching a
different demographic.
- Yeah, getting on, so Stay Dangerous,
the concept, the album.
You know what I'm saying, it
really came from the streets.
That's the lingo where I'm from right now,
that's how we talk, and
it's like gang culture.
But I'm just taking
that and I'm applying it
because when I really,
that when you sit down
and you think about it,
it's like stay dangerous,
you know what I'm saying, that's a way,
that's a way of living,
that's a way of life.
- It's a mindset.
- Yeah, it's a mindset.
- It maps to everything.
- Exactly, like knowledge is dangerous.
- 100%.
- Education and all that,
you know what I'm saying?
So it's like I'm trying to spread,
I'm trying to spread
that out wide like that.
- You see that as a positive, right?
- Hell yeah.
- That's how I see it.
- No you can add that to anything.
- 'Cause I'm aware of it and I'm like
that's the same shit I'm
saying, just different words.
- Exactly, yeah.
- And obviously different circumstances.
It's just so interesting
to watch that skillset
which is very foreign to most
people that you grew up with.
It's the same shit.
It's just people don't
get it, it's all so basic.
Those 80 year old white guys
in the big towers over there,
they're playing that same game.
They're just using, they're
just using different weapons.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Same shit.
- Exactly.
- Two sides, same, you know, it's just,
people are confused.
- Somewhere in that though,
in that shift, you realize.
- That high, low.
- Yeah, that high one that,
you know, shifts at some point,
you, the insecurity gets pushed
away and you realize like yo
we can do anything we want.
- My man, anything, and I'm telling you,
and I'm telling you, and I'm telling you,
and I'm telling you, you're hungry bro.
ADD if you call it ambition, I understand.
It's not like you're drawn into, you know,
you're trying to make money my guy.
ADD when it's ambition is exactly right.
- He's the hardest working
artist I have ever met.
- Stop gassing man.
(laughs)
- I wouldn't say it if I didn't mean it,
I don't say that I love...
- [Gary] She's on the
record, she's got people
she's gonna have to answer to already.
She's about to get, she's
about to get a text,
she's about to get a text in
a week, she's on the record.
- Like my boy Mike gonna hit
you like what you mean, yeah.
- Uh-huh, uh-huh.
- Mike well made it, like.
- [Sarah] Yeah, you're on
YG's team for real now.
- Uh-huh.
- But the other thing about stay dangerous
that I really respect about you is he's,
you speak your mind man.
Like when you said the Donald Trump stuff
or whatever, you like
see someone out of line,
or when you just do whatever,
it's all respectful,
because so many people area
afraid to do what you do.
- Mike, Mike, that's the
best part of the advantage
of what he grew up with.
- Exactly.
- Saying that shit is not scary
compared to what he really,
like that's kind of like
my thing, my thing is
I love losing so much,
meaning the process, the game,
the going up the hill, that losing,
like the way people think
I'm crazy, they don't get it,
I want to weirdly lose,
I weirdly wanna go back
to studio apartment in Queens
with eight family members
because then everyone's gonna shit on me
and then I'm gonna be like uh-huh,
I'm gonna rise like the Phoenix
and fuckin' punk all of you
back in your mouth 'cause you shit on me.
Like so it, you know what I mean?
- Oh for sure.
- When people are like oh
that's crazy that you said that.
You must be thinking like motherfucker
do you understand what my real life was?
- Exactly.
- That's why, people don't get it,
the biggest advantages in
life are coming up with zero
right now, now.
Not your grandfather, but right
now if you're lucky enough
that you know what zero tastes like
and you weren't given anything
and you're not entitled.
You're fucking set,
because the fucking game
is rigged in your favor 'cause it's open,
meanwhile if you grew up
super rich and privileged
and handed everything, you're finished,
because the institutions
that used to take care of you
are losing, got it?
And you don't know how to get yours,
you weren't taught to hunt.
You were just fed, you
were fed from the get
so you have no idea how to
go out and fucking hunt.
- I feel that.
- My man, I swear to
God on life in a world
where I fuck with you kind of characters
and I fuck with like hedge fund babies,
I swear on my children's health
if you ask me who I feel worse for,
a kid right now growing
up on the upper East side
going to private school who's
got 10 million in the bank
or a kid in the outskirts
of Atlanta or Crenshaw
I feel worse for the white kid.
And I'm not, or the black kid, I just had,
I just had a kid who's got a lot,
but I can't, you know, precise,
he's got a lot of money.
I'm like you're gonna
lose, I looked him up.
Like he's just, when you've been fed...
- Set up for disaster.
- Especially now.
Because when you were fed in the 60s
well you just got fed
back into a bigger machine
when you grew up and you
were part of the country club
and this and that, it
wasn't based on merit.
It was based on what your last name was.
Your grandfather named the library.
Like it was a rigged game.
Listen, there's still
racism, there's still sexism,
there's still plenty of
shit, but the internet
doesn't give a fuck.
(YG laughs)
- That's facts.
- It just is, it just is.
- The internet don't give a fuck.
- It just doesn't, and that's why things
are breaking through,
because even as put on
and with the streets and everything else,
you guys know what
happened the last 20 years
in your guys' game.
Yeah, somebody would break through
and as soon as they broke through
they put on defense, they
became the suppressor,
even though they look the part.
But people are confused.
Got it?
They, because they had
financial advantages
to keep it suppressed.
They would just look at what he was doing,
siphon it, and then be it, and pay no tax.
And the streets love
them, oh you fuck with us.
Uh-uh, you're siphoning us.
That's the truth.
That's the, you know, I
love when people are like,
white this, white America is doing this.
I'm like motherfuckers you better look.
- I was just talking to my boy about that.
- Deep.
- It is deep.
- And it's a brain fuck, and honestly
I would've never understood
it had this era not come.
Because then I was like
oh shit, this is actually
what's happening.
- I was just talking to my
boy about that same concept
how cats will grow and get to that level,
and instead of sticking with the mindset
and treating everybody I knew as far as
I wanna make money, I wanna be this, this,
it's like let me capitalize
on, on your needs, right?
- It's why we win.
We've been investing this forever.
You know, people are
like, people hit me up,
they're like you're fucking with hip-hop.
I'm like we've been
doing this for a decade.
I'm like I just have
something to give now.
- That's smart.
- You know?
Like I'm here like what?
- She knows better than anyone.
- That's real shit.
- 'Cause all that shit that
we talked about in the past
that was all with him.
All the Avion, we did Avion
with him for his birthday.
- Motherfucker, you know
how much money I put in.
Like not for my health.
- That's talking about the drink.
- Tequila, yeah.
- Yeah, we connected Jeezy with that.
- Oh y'all connected Jeezy with the,
fuck, what's the owner?
- Kenny Austin, that's us.
- Yeah, that's my boy.
- That's us, my guy,
and we were doing that.
- That's crazy.
- And that's it.
- God damn.
- And that's it, and
honestly once that stuff
started working, then I was like fuck it,
I'm gonna build a machine.
And so that's what I've been up to.
Now we can, and back to the high low,
can I put him today with
Chase Bank, still not yet,
they're still Serena and Steph Curry,
but in four to eight months.
- Well that's what's so interesting about
the timing right now and
everything he has going on
I think a year from now there
should be a perception of YG
as like a businessman is
gonna be completely changed.
I think those around
him know it super well,
but I think...
- To your point, you're 100%.
Honestly that's the plug
that I think I'm gonna fit,
that's why I'm spending
a lot of time listening,
I'm just meeting listening,
bringing love, our playlist,
just giving love, right?
It's just respect.
And as soon as one domino go, you know,
people are willing to flare up,
but if you've given them no reason to
they prefer not to.
- Yeah.
- right?
- They prefer not to.
Unfortunately, if said domino falls.
(Gary laughs)
- All right, yeah.
That's good.
- Anything we can help
with from what you know
about anything, anything come to mind.
I really like your music to begin with.
I'm excite, we will, what's cool about
what I think we're
doing is we're so scaled
in the entrepreneurial
community, high, low, right?
Like 81 to 18, that we're just giving
so much exposure to artists.
Like you're winning,
you've won your thing,
but there's just all this
pocket of people that,
all they, they just aren't
consuming in the channels
to hear it, but they're consuming
me, but they still love it
it's the same shit it's just this pocket
that we have right now, so
that will definitely do.
I think the more interesting
part for me though
is why I wanted to have this meeting
is it's very obvious that
the ambition of the process
is deeper, right?
And so to me like everybody
is young even though I'm old,
like everyone is young
here, I'm gonna be working
for the next 40 years, and
I believe in what I said
about what I started with,
so like to me this is,
the reason I want.
People are always asking me
like why are you doing that?
I'm like, you don't
understand, if I give love
with asking for nothing
in return for six, seven,
eight years, I'm thinking
about 17 years from now.
Actually to be very frank...
- You're gonna be on point,
you'll be all your life
mothafuckas go like,
dawg, don't fuck with him,
this is the guy.
(laughs)
No, you gonna get that back for sure.
- That's right, and the best part is
honestly on a very real
kick, I actually don't wanna
even ask in 17 years, my
preference is to give it
and never even ask for it.
Do my thing, right?
- You got to have it.
- Exactly, so then people are
just cheering for you, right?
- Yeah.
- So yeah I mean like, you
know, back to the acting
or the writing, like
look, we have unlimited
roll of decks of relationships
and understanding
and you guys have all that
too, but like anywhere,
like to me it's more just about asking.
Like I like being asked,
I prefer being asked,
so like we just need
to know what, you know?
- Actually the dopest part
to just as we're moving
and mitigating...
- So actually, I got a question
where I can really help
on the brand side, the core brand.
How much of it is sold direct to consumer?
- That's like a big, that's really...
- That's the fucking question, all of it?
- Year one and two was
all direct to consumer.
- How is that being sold and distributed?
- Shop5, Ecom.
- Shop5 Plus or regular?
- Regular shops, plus we just
deal with the Shop5 people.
- Uh-huh, you go to 3PL.
Like you do your, you pack yourselves?
- Yeah, yeah, we have all that stuff.
- 3PL.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, mm-hmm.
- Fulfillment and all of them things down.
We usually like partner
with a bigger company
that had all of them things,
for structure for us,
and then we went to, you
know, some big box retailers
on kinda lower end T-shirt brands.
- Which ones?
- Zumiez.
And how are you driving
direct to consumer sales?
Just his social?
(YG claps)
- This is the fucking combo.
Yeah!
Boy this is all, I've
been trying, that's crazy.
- [Sarah] That's all
he's been talking about
for the last like couple of weeks.
- Yeah, I've been on the
digital, marketing, back end,
strategy, trying to figure
it out on like who really to,
like the best company to
link with, you feel me,
to run all that.
- Feel you, I've been fucking building it,
of course I feel you.
- Man bro, that's crazy, I've been talking
about this shit for like a
week, gonna have like five means
of all digital marketing.
- And what, they're
all just quant based DR
like Bath Kids, right?
Like conversion based Cack
LTV, blah, blah, blah.
That's not the right game,
that's half the equation.
It's art and math together
making that birth child.
- [Sarah] Right, I think that's what like
we're trying to figure
out who the right people.
- Can I give you the answer?
- Don't partner with anybody,
let me help you hire some people.
- We were just saying that yesterday.
- [Sarah] Literally.
- We were just saying that yesterday,
we gotta hire some people.
- Don't hire, don't
fucking part with anybody,
they're in the business of
making money off of you.
They can't, they're not even bad,
it's like the same old psychology, right?
It's just the way they
are, they're a company,
they can't try hard enough for you
'cause they have to make money too.
And then the game were to,
and in some places it works.
Management, management works,
incentives are aligned,
it's a percentage of the cut aligned.
Not aligned when somebody,
like when they're running
your media and your art against your sales
'cause they've gotta make a vig.
Where I can really help is
that we've been doing it
for a decade, I've got
people who've left me
and are sad that they
left 'cause they left
for 5,000 dollars more
money and they wanted to buy
a nice bracelet and now
they have a bullshit job
and they wanna come back,
but I won't take 'em.
But I love 'em.
That's the kind of
people I can send to you.
Where would they have to live, LA?
Which they would love, LA's
the best, I'm just trying.
- The art side would have to be in LA,
but then the digital side not necessarily.
- I would want it to be in LA too.
I want them together.
You wanna really sell shit?
Together.
I want them sitting like
this, do you understand?
- Like when you say art
and the other stuff like.
- The pictures and the videos
that make people do shit.
- Oh yeah, for sure, okay.
- You understand?
- Yeah.
- [Sarah] You see, it's kind of what
we were talking about,
using the right content.
- Yeah.
- [Sarah] You know, and using
the right back end stuff.
- Yeah.
- Let me give you an example.
We send you this whole video.
You guys find the one minute
that you like the best,
that positioned you the
best, you run that video
against fans of me on
Facebook with a call to action
to buy your shit at the end,
you will sell some shit.
That game.
- Yeah, for sure.
- [Sarah] Like I just, we want somebody
who gets it and who understands it.
Not just somebody who's
gonna sell him a dream
and just sit on the computer all day,
you know, that's I think
what's really important.
You know, we've been
talking about it, it's like.
- You're hiring, listen to
me, you're hiring somebody.
- Yeah, for sure.
- It's not, I mean it's
not rocket science,
you know what I mean?
- No, no, honestly man, it's a skill,
like right, here's what I would say.
Make the investments so
they're part of the family.
- For sure.
- The end.
- Wow.
- You can't rent the important shit.
- Mm-hmm.
(Gary laughs)
- We're on deck, man bro, I'm on deck bro.
I'm on deck, yeah.
- The good thing is though that first year
we built it all, direct to consumers,
you know what I mean, so
that's how the majority
of our business is.
- I figured.
- And even with the Zumiez.
- Like our online still killing it.
- Of course.
- Yeah.
- 100, that's where you should.
- And like I said earlier their stuff is,
like they're doing some of
the best out of everybody.
You know, 2 Chainz, you,
like there's very small
handful of people who
do merch well in hip hop
and you're one of them.
- I gotta correct you
though, this is fashion,
this is not a merch people.
- Oh yeah, there you go.
- No, no, honestly, that's an important.
No, no, right, and 2 Chainz is
doing like Christmas sweaters
I'm with you, I think that's right.
- We're a fashion company.
- [Sarah] Yeah, I think and
that's a big difference.
- And Chainz is doing his thing,
but like you know, I think that's,
and honestly, when people, like
this is an interesting thing
it's funny when you say it
what went through my mind.
I'm laughing because
everybody on their Instagram
and their profile, it says entrepreneur.
- [Sarah] I love the people
who can't even spell it.
- I know, which is fine, I
can't spell for shit either
so I'm not even gonna gas them on that,
my question is that's like me
saying rapper in my profile.
I could, I can go into, we
just built a studio in here,
I can go in, I could.
Am I getting paid, do people fuck with it?
Like and that's how I'm
thinking about fashion brands,
like to me, the ambition of, right,
like people, like everybody's
got a fashion brand,
everybody on Instagram has
got a brand, you know why?
They took 50 dollars, they
pressed some fucking statement
on a T-shirt down the way, they posted it
on their Instagram and they think
they're fucking Louis Vuitton.
(YG laughs)
- Oh shit yeah.
- [Sarah] I think both are necessary
at least somebody like YG like
to build the fashion brand
I mean he also needs that
merch that's accessible
to that, you know, 13
year old girl in Iowa.
- So I would say that that's right,
but I do think there's a smart way
to have that conversation
because where you're at now
in the beginning if you were, if this was,
when did the brand come out?
- Officially about a year and a half ago.
- And when did the music
career really start
kind of like bubblin' for real?
- From the O 10.
- Right, so if this 2015 I
would like think in merch
and fashion brand terms, right?
To me at the scale that
you guys are at right now,
look, Louis Vuitton sells like 19 dollar,
like it's not about the price,
it's about the thought process.
- And that was like our
original conversation
when we talked about this
brand, he came to me,
was like yo we need help
on merch, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I just felt like merch
was corny at the time,
this was when merch was really out.
And it was like yo, I mean
we grew up Roc-a-Fella,
all these cats, we're like
yo, let's build a brand
that we can parallel and
use the label's money
and all these people's money to grow
and parallel his career, you know?
That's what 400 came
from, I was like YG 400,
that's the block he grew up on,
it's where like artists
turn 400 into a lifestyle,
Forever 100, staying true
to yourself, you know?
- Love that.
- And so that became something
that other people don't have.
Really like build a back story to it
on how he got to where he
is, the whole, you know?
It gives us some more
substance than just merch,
you know what I mean?
- What are you guys doing in New York?
- Well, fuck, what are we doing Sarah?
- Had a long night last night.
- That's good.
That's exactly what you should be doing.
That's exactly what you
should be doing in New York.
- Yeah, no, we've been out here politic,
you know, we have a label meeting,
played 'em the album,
talked about the concept.
- How did that go?
- [Sarah] Amazing, and we would have some
back to back to back to back meetings.
- Like just fire, fire, fire.
The music is the fucking gateway drug.
Period.
Like I don't get people.
You wanna hear an interesting story?
I met this old dude, I
was raising some money
for some shit back in the
day, I met this old dude,
it was a weird meeting,
everything else was like
hedge funds and family offices.
This was just like a rogue character.
And I was excited 'cause I'm
rogue and I'm like whatever,
you know, I was excited for the meeting.
But we basically didn't
even talk about the deal
'cause in two seconds I realized,
actually I think he was
representing Katy Perry,
that was it, she wanted
to invest in something
I was up to, but very quickly I was like
this is not gonna be right.
So we're just shooting, you
know, having a drink, right?
He tells me that he
was the manager of Styx
which was a big rock band
back in the day, got it?
I was telling him about this new world,
he was like fuck man, interesting.
And he made a connection,
a good connection.
He goes do you know that sticks
when MTV came out we were
one of the biggest bands
in the world and they
came to us and they said,
yo, and people were
making their own videos.
They're like we'll pay you to make a video
thinking they were doing him a favor.
And they were like go fuck yourself.
You think we're gonna make a music video?
That's fucking music that's free.
They thought in 1984
that making a music video
and if they put it on MTV was taking away
from their album sales
at the record store.
So fuck you for making
me wanna do a video.
And you gotta remember,
MTV is now poppin',
every kid in America is
watching that has cable,
and there's only like eight
music videos on rotation.
So Madonna, and Prince,
and Michael Jackson,
and everybody you fucking
know in that world,
those are iconics, and the
people that had their moment,
Twisted Sister, Duran Duran were all based
on the people that said yes to the video.
So now I'm telling artists
every day that they come through
and I'm sure you've seen
some of it, and if not,
like fucking make music
and just give it to fuck,
like make music as much,
if you got music in you,
make it and get it heard,
give it to vloggers,
give it to fucking.
Nothing would make me happier than fucking
some E-Sports kid playing
Twitch rocking my shit
in the background, with what,
a million people watching?
People don't get it,
music's the gateway drug.
Like make money on music but
like that supply and demand
like I don't give a fuck if you
got the fucking hottest bars
there's eight trillion bars.
Like you could be mad at people,
the market's always right.
Shows is access, we'll
always pay for access.
You know how many people are
gonna pay 100,000 dollars
to have dinner with you in 10 years.
That's real.
People don't get it.
People don't understand
how to build blocks.
- You kicking some shit bro.
- I'm trying.
- People would pay a lot of money
to have dinner with you right now.
- How much you got Mike?
(Mike laughs)
- Oh man.
- We gotta finish our negotiations
so you have a little more so you can.
- I can't wait till
that type of shit comes.
- It's just real man.
- And you could have it now.
- Especially if you execute it.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah, but, but the longer
you can hold your breath
the more you're gonna get.
So just keep chopping
and making, keep making,
keep adding victories.
You fucking build a billion
dollar fashion brand
that opens up some third
generation Italian family
24 year old that wants
to have dinner with you
because yeah, you're cool,
but way more importantly
you built a big brand
and her company's brand
is getting fucked up and
she wants to turn it around.
So how do you actually,
so like, the angles that,
people used to wanna pay
me to have wine with me
'cause I was the wine guy.
Until they wanted to have dinner with me
for a different reason, you know?
But like my business
people that fuck the way
I roll, they're like why do you do this,
why do you do this for him and why do you,
more importantly, why do I do it for them?
All my shit's free.
And they think I'm giving it away,
and I'm like you're just confused.
You're running a sprint
and I'm running a marathon.
You know?
- Sound like somebody I know.
My nigga Mill.
- That was probably the most
interesting meeting of them all
it happened so fast.
- That was the best meeting.
We were in Nipsey's studio.
- Yeah bro, he be on.
He on some shit.
- Man, I gotta tell you,
when we finally connected
in studio there was instant,
we kinda looked at each other
and in like five minutes
we were like mm-hmm.
- When I saw you guys I was
like oh I gotta watch this one.
- 'Cause you knew.
- I know how he thinks, that's my boy too.
You know what I mean?
Like I know how he thinks
and I know how you think,
you know, and he's always
like trying to figure out
like what's coming next.
He, I knew he was looking
forward to that meeting.
Even when me and Nip did
that 100 Dollar album thing
it was like that was,
that was him coming to me
and be like yo Mill was like...
- [Gary] This is what we're gonna do.
- He talked about it for so much
and almost a year like yo, how did we,
we gotta make the product worth more,
you know, we gotta make people respect it,
and that's what we're
doing with this brand,
it's like yo, respect
it at a higher level.
- All you're doing is deploying
empathy to the consumer.
People don't get it.
Once they hit a certain
level like this man
they start trying to
take from the consumer
instead of give.
That's all you did, it's very basic.
You wanna figure everything out?
Make it phenomenal.
You'll sell unlimited T-shirts or fashion
if every time I buy a fashion thing
I get a two minute Facetime with him.
Here's the problem, he
doesn't have that time.
So you work backwards.
But that's how you do
it, you work backwards.
People try to do the least,
I try to do the most,
and then figure out what's real.
If I can do this 97
times with every artist
that I would fuck with, I would,
I can't, so I do a
little bit of less than,
but I still do it.
You understand?
Everyone's trying to do the least,
what's the most scale, where
can I make the most money?
No, no, if you buy a
fucking 30 dollar hoodie
you come and be my homie for a year.
You start with that,
that's not gonna work,
cool, next, and you
finally land with something
that's bringing so much more value
because when you chopped
it all the way down,
you're still here, those
motherfuckers started down here
of what they wanted to do for people.
So when they have a meeting like this,
so I go I will do something a little nice.
They just ended up here.
We started with I'm gonna
give you my fucking soul.
And then I ended up
here 'cause that's real.
Got it?
And that's, the game.
- Facts.
- I gotta get back to work.
(dramatic instrumental music)